[Applause]
I know it's a clay
[Music]
and I think I know why your how you'd
say it every week but this time I really
made it why you're happy today Trump has
left the country I feel lighter already
I this supposed to be help parents feel
when they send their kids off to summer
camp
you know just but it's a 12 day trip to
Asia 12 days in somebody asked Trump
before they said who's in charge while
you're gone and he said who's in charge
when I'm here he's going to China Japan
the Philippines Vietnam South Korea all
the countries with factories that make
his make America great again hats of
course where China is the big one he
wants it he wants to study their wall he
said when's the last time you saw a
Mexican in Beijing
but then South Korea Trump will be in
South Korea that should be fun
TMZ meets DMZ and then Vietnam where of
course there was a war that Trump
avoided with multiple deferments because
of his bone spurs and now he gets to go
back as president of the United States
who says the Dodgers didn't win
[Music]
[Applause]
I know Angele you're very upset about
that sorry about that but did you at
least have a good Halloween because Oh
Halloween what I don't know what you
gave the kids this Halloween but over at
Robert Muller's house they were handing
out indictments this is just the
beginning but Paul Manafort who was
Trump's campaign manager the head guy at
the Gabbay they're 12 count indictment
money laundering tax evasion failing to
register as a foreign agent lying about
all of it
and I love this he had three passports I
didn't know you could do that three
American passports at Trump he was gonna
drain the swamp then he hires The
Creature from the Black Lagoon there's a
new character we'll have to build a new
evidence wall
George papadopolis never heard of this
guy he was go getter there meeting with
the Russians we'll talk about it but he
was he was reporting to a big up in the
campaign name Sam Clovis you know Sam
there's Sam Clovis
this week get this Trump picked to be
the department of agriculture's chief
scientist and then Sam withdrew when he
remembered he was not a scientist
and they asked mr. Clovis you know what
expertise do you have regarding
agriculture and he said eating but
speaking of eating our seed cord let me
tell you the B Republicans unveiled
finally this week their new tax plan so
hang on America's billionaires help is
on the way
and it's amazing I mean remember the Tea
Party the Tea Party back in 2009-2010
the way they took over Congress but
based on their bedrock principles that
debt is out of control
our biggest crisis an existential threat
to our way of life you have to get all
that yeah this new tax plan it blows a
1.5 trillion dollar hole in the tab in
the debt and someone someone asked Paul
Ryan he they said when when did
Republicans stop caring about debt and
he explained after careful consideration
that the current president is white
[Applause]
so and of course you know there was
another horrible terrorist attack in New
York Trump immediately started tweeting
stupid weak president doesn't keep us
safe and then he was like oh wait that's
me now but here's the feel-good story of
the week you heard what happened at
Twitter on the last day at work an
employee there and employees there oh I
got deleted Trump's Twitter account for
eleven minutes I don't know who this
person is but I have one thing to say to
them thank you for your service
[Applause]